bueno las principales conclusiones son
que estamos viviendo una crisis
climática sin precedentes hay ejemplos
de esto digamos inundaciones aumento del
nivel del mar
pérdida de biodiversidad deforestación
necesitamos digamos tomar acciones
concretas particularmente los países que
se comprometen al acuerdo de parís
aumentar esas ambiciones para reducir
las los gases de efecto invernadero y
así poder ir controlando la situación
ambiental que tenemos tanto en argentina
como en el resto del mundo bueno y
hablemos ahora justamente de esas tareas
pendientes de la comunidad internacional
para luchar contra la crisis climática
que podemos hacer de ahora en adelante
bueno la última cumbre de naciones
unidas que se desarrolló en glasgow
escocia dejó digamos sabor a poco en una
cumbre en la que se tenía mucha
expectativa había sido suspendida por el
commit 19 pero lamentablemente las
ambiciones de los países fueron digamos
muy bajas necesitamos aumentar esas
ambiciones los países tienen que
entender que se vive una realidad
digamos grave
ustedes bien decían que hay desastres en
colorado en diferentes partes del mundo
y esos desastres digamos son
consecuencia de la crisis de
biodiversidad y climática que vivimos
hay que actuar cuanto antes si lo que
queremos es un futuro digamos sostenible
para las generaciones que vienen